the division has no story this is one of
those comments that I receive in a
similar way to a lot of people who get
the this game is Dead statement while I
don't necessarily think it's for
everyone in this video I'm going to
explain why I think the way the division
tells the story as well as many other
games like it is actually the best way
to do
[Music]
it
regarding the story at the very most
basic level I think we could group
Gamers into these three categories no
story those who don't really care about
the story at all and solely focus on the
gameplay setting those who need a decent
setting in order to spark interest in
the game but place a larger emphasis on
gameplay all story those who place an
equal amount of importance on the story
and gameplay obviously this is super
oversimplifying it larger Publishers
will have marketing teams that could
break this down several several more
times but in the interest of keeping
this video concise let's just stick to
these three now I won't pretend that I
know the ratio of players around each of
these and to be fair I'd say this varies
quite considerably depending on the
genre and game also I don't necessarily
think that everyone sits bang on each of
these categories a lot likely sit
somewhere in between to further explain
this I'll use myself as an example I sit
right in the middle with a new game I'm
a gamer who seeks a little bit of
immersion before I can get into it but
I'm certainly more concerned about the
gameplay to start with it needs to be
fun we're playing a video game after all
it should be entertaining
however once I've established that I
like the gaml that's when I would
probably start moving down towards the
all story category the longer I play the
game the more I want to be able to dig
up without a decent story my attention
begins to
wander it's probably worth noting at
this point that I'm basing this on live
service games I know this is apparently
a bad word among a lot of popular
content creators but for me personally
I'm a fan I've been playing games for a
long time and the idea of a game and
franchise that is constantly evolving
appeals far more than single play
through games these days I love that
time spent regardless of how little time
I have can be shown in game whether that
be experience gear limited time
Collectibles Etc this is part of the
gameplay experience that I look for I
want to put 1,000 hours into a game not
just 20 to
40 the division tells a story in a way
that began with a powerful marketing
campaign that really set the scene with
a number of videos that talked about the
situation at hand in a way that almost
seemed like real life as it tied in with
a number of things that actually played
out in the past yet when the game
finally came out we were greeted with a
strong opening trailer and then that was
pretty much it for the most part the
rest of the story played out in the
agent earpiece while running through the
world or playing missions on top of this
there are Collectibles that you can
stumble across or actively hunt out and
this is where the depth of the story
comes from these would play
automatically when you pick them up in
game but you have the option to listen
to them again through your catalog the
division 2 followed a similar pattern
until seasons were introduced with them
the coms were given while running
through no hunting down required and the
same goes with descent and other
activities like the incursion the
information and will building kep piling
through let's go back to those three
categories for a second based on what I
just talked about with the division it
would be fair to say that two of these
groups would assume that there is maybe
a good setting but there has been very
little in the way of story since the
beginning and this is fair if you don't
really care about it why put the work
into hunting it out and collecting the
Intel that tells the story I'm pretty
sure if you ask someone from this
category what the game is about they
probably say it's something about a
virus and a guy named Alex I think there
would even be a decent number of people
from this category that would dislike
the way the division story is told and
maybe rely on some kiwi dude with a
monotone voice to piece everything
together but let's flip it around for a
second what if we talk about a game that
is very heavy on story Starfield I only
bring this one up because it was the
first one that came to mind and the most
recent game of the type that I've played
there are tons of B examples but I think
this still works it's a good game and
was generally well received by The
Gaming Community but it does isolate a
few of these groups I am a story player
and I still got frustrated with a number
of dialogue cuts and the heavy focus on
run to this guy to talk to this guy
about this other guy because he said
mean things about the first guy
eventually I ended up just skipping the
lines and lines of talking by Smashing
the space bar over and over just to rush
through the NPC interactions and let's
face it the only thing you should be
smashing is that like And subscribe
button to support this channel yeah that
was probably the cheesiest most YouTuber
douchebaggery that I've ever said
on this channel well sadly it probably
isn't regardless I make no apologies
anyway I felt like I was spending more
time listening to voice actors than
playing the game I played for maybe 40
hours and that was an absolute slog to
get there but it isn't because I thought
the game was bad it just really wasn't
the right game for me and I can imagine
there are a lot of other players even
less focused on the story that felt much
the same although maybe in a far less
polite way games like the division and
Destiny who keep their story deep
without forcing it into the face of
everyone who plays the game are keeping
the game more viable for a large number
of players at the end of the day
especially for live service titles we
want our favorite games to be popular
enough that they continue to be
supported by the studios so for the
people who don't give a crap about the
story not to be bothered about constant
cut scenes and dialogue and for those
who don't really care to begin with but
may be swayed once they hit their stride
with the gameplay and mechanics then of
course the ones who place just as much
importance on the story as the gameplay
there is still a ton to dig up and
construct I know I said earlier that
this third group could be split up
several more times and that a good chunk
of them would prefer to have everything
in the story played out in front of them
and that's cool I understand this this
would be your classic single player
story mode games I've played a ton of
them I get it but times are changing
attention spans are dropping short style
videos are up full length videos are
down Etc Studios need to cater to this
change in order to get the player base
to justifi continued support there will
always be a place for primarily story
focused games I just believe that Their
audience will only get smaller over time
I actually feel like the games who don't
throw the whole story in front of you
are able to go into considerably more
depth because they UNC constrained with
the gameplay story balance issue yes you
may not get all of the pretty cinematics
but if I wanted more cinematics than
gameplay I'd go and watch a movie plus I
love when something is found several
years after the game releases that
changes everything we thought you knew
about a
situation I actually reached out to
Lauren Stone the artive director on the
division just to get her thoughts on
what I've been discussing here and she
summed it up far more elegantly than I
could The Narrative cannot get in the
way of the game play especially in
multiplayer we are conditioned to
believe that it only counts a story if
it's in a cut scene that you can hold a
to skip that's a really expensive way to
make it really easy to skip the story
The Way We Tell story in the division is
not linear it's not plot driven it's
character driven character is King
because people are constantly evolving
and changing how we see the world evolve
by our knowledge and perspective I treat
the story as its own game mechanic it's
for the analysts for the people who want
to understand the world so they can save
what remains because they know what is
worth saving and the more grounded we
can make these stories and those stories
serve the mediums we are working in the
more we can build this universe we have
created it's why we make comics novels
audio dramas and are working on
redacted every medium has its
limitations and I look at those
constraints as opportunities and try to
build these products in a way that
supports one another while being
independent for the story nerds when
this is all over I hope you love what
we've done and like the story in the
game you don't need to experience
everything to enjoy anything but if
you're a completionist like me the trans
media will become more and more relevant
as we move
forward I like the comment you made
around being conditioned to believe it
only counts a story if it's in a cut
scene and I think this is exactly where
the X game has no story movement has
come from games in general are changing
the shear size and complexity of them
has grown exponentially over the last
couple of decades but equally so have
our expectations as Gamers studios are
having to employ hundreds if not
thousands of developers in order to keep
a single title supported and at the same
time they're a business so need to turn
a profit if this is the future of
Storytelling and gaming and I honestly
think it is for the larger AAA titles
I'm actually all for it yes we have a
few list cut scenes but the detail we
are gaining in turn is of far greater
value to me and that's without
considering all of the trans media
coming out these
days believe it or not this video was
originally intended to be a YouTube
short but making anything under 60
seconds seems to be a challenge for me
these days before I close this video I
wanted to say a huge thank you to
everyone this is well overdue the
channel hit 100,000 subscribers last
month in fact I think it's sitting at
117,000 as of writing this given how
seldom I upload and the fact that I
break almost every single YouTube
algorithm rule it blows my mind that the
channel has made it this far I also
really need to recognize the support
I've received from Ubisoft a andz and
well actually a whole bunch of Ubisoft
Studios especially massive entertainment
I won't name everyone because I'll
definitely miss someone but you know you
are both past and present when I first
started talking to working with and
visiting the team at massive I think I
was at barely 8,000 Subs I was in a
position where I wasn't actually sure
whether I was going to continue with
this whole YouTube thing but they
indirectly Tau me not to be afraid of
being unique to be myself you may not
grow as fast as the typical channel to
begin with but you'll have a hell of a
lot more fun along the way do what makes
you happy anyway I'm going to wrap this
one up if you made it this far thank you
very much for watching and I'll catch
you soon in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers